- [Nihachu] Stop calling people cringe
and letting them enjoy what they wanna do.
- [Sipover] Rude, I mean,
do you wanna role play
as a pregnant pig?
Go for it.
- Yeah, you do you.
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Minecraft
role play is cringe.
Three,
two,
one,
go.
(calm music)
- [Sipover] I've done a little bit
of role playing in my times.
So I feel like it
wouldn't be right for
me to say it's cringe,
but you got the couple
of odd balls out there.
I will be honest,
but the majority of it is over looked,
usually it's not that bad.
- [TapL] Yeah, I agree.
There's always gonna be like bad role play
but since Minecraft is
like a game that you could do anything,
you can make some really
good role play out of it.
- [Nihachu] What I just wanna say is
stop calling people cringe
and let them enjoy what they wanna do,
you know?
- Rude.
- I mean, If you wanna role play
as a pregnant pig
go for it.
- You do you.
- [BadBoyHalo] There's a
lot of Minecraft role play
that if I saw it I'd be like,
"Yeah, this isn't something
I would want to watch
and I might not find it to my liking
which is why I'm like in the middle
because it's like some of it I might like,
some of it I might not."
- [Hannahxxrose] Yeah, I agree with that.
And I was also thinking
when we do our own type of role play
and like the Dream SMP
there are definitely times
when I felt a little bit cringe
where I didn't know what to do or
just because I haven't done it much before
so that's kind of why I'm in
the middle, but I really do.
I do really like doing it,
but there are times
where I kind of felt a little bit cringe.
- [Narrator] Creating content
has affected my mental health.
Three,
two,
one,
go.
(calm music)
- [TapL] Definitely when
you're making content,
there's a level of
expectation that not only you,
but other people have on you
so then that could affect
your mental health definitely.
- [BadBoyHalo] I think
whenever anything is like
when you make a source
of income, obviously,
it's gonna have an effect
on you mentally and anyway.
- [Nihachu] Yeah, I totally agree
with what you're saying Bad
and I also wanna add
that it's not just that,
but it's also a lot of us kind
of fall into this out of luck
or out of any other reason very young
and no one will explain to us how,
for example, to do taxes,
or how to all of a sudden handle
so many people looking at us
or all of these things that
you didn't learn or no one
told you and no one will/
- [Narrator] Minecraft
content is getting repetitive.
Three,
two,
one,
go.
(calm music)
- [BadBoyHalo] It's interesting because
there are some video concepts
that are making a
resurgence and coming back
that I've seen years ago.
And so you'll see it years
ago and then it's like,
"Oh my goodness,
why is this video coming back?"
So that's why part of me
wanted to go and agree,
but there's also every day
it's like someone's
coming up with a new idea.
- [TapL] Yeah, I think YouTube rewards you
for doing really repetitive content.
You can make thousands
of Minecraft butt videos
and get rewarded for it.
And I think that's why a
lot of YouTubers do it.
- [McYum] I think from my perspective
at least Minecraft is literally
just a tool for creation.
It's not even seen as a game
because you can do so much within it.
And I feel like, especially on YouTube,
it has the potential
to transcend Minecraft as a game itself.
So, I think there's still loads
of fresh content to be made.
- [Narrator] I spend more
time in Minecraft than IRL.
Three,
two,
one,
go.
(calm music)
- [TapL] I used to just
play eight hours a day.
Just literally I would grind it
like how league players grind it.
I would just play it.
I'd play competitively.
So I would have to just play a lot
in order for me to be good.
So I'd have this standard for myself.
And now my competitiveness
is through my work.
So for me to maintain my
competitiveness in the game
I have to just keep playing.
- [Hannahxxrose] Yeah, Harvey,
I used to be the same way.
I used to play eight hours a day
for four years straight
just because that was
my content back then,
the competitive style, stuff.
- Yeah, like UHC, right?
- Yeah, UHC.
And I felt like that was
the only way to get better.
And to make my content better,
I would have to be better
and I'd have to do the next best thing.
You know what I mean?
Now it's definitely a lot better
so that's why I'm somewhere in the middle.
But in the past,
I would've been at the very left line.
- [BadBoyHalo] When I did a lot of
PVP content back in the day
I definitely was more open in that camp.
But now that it's mostly
streaming, hanging out
on my friends' streams,
recording videos with my
friends and things like that,
it's definitely a lot less grindy
'cause you definitely do have to grind
if you're trying to
get good at PVP and things like that.
- [Antfrost] I could be
where Harvey is standing
and I got to be here.
I put slightly disagree,
'cause at the moment I generally don't.
I'll play for an hour or two a day maybe.
Sometimes I'll maybe play for six hours.
Other days I'll play literally none.
So I try to limit it now.
- [Narrator] The mind craft player base
is dominated by guys.
Three,
two,
one,
go.
(calm music)
- [Hannahxxrose] Especially this year,
I feel like I've seen so
many girls join the community
and be a part of the gaming community
and the Minecraft community.
Especially, especially in
the Dream SMP community.
You can see it all over
Twitter, all over TikTok.
There's so many girls that maybe
just got into it this year
or have been in the community
and they were maybe too afraid to say
that they were,
I think it's definitely like 50 /50.
- [BadBoyHalo] So yeah,
if we're talking about the people
who consume Minecraft content,
gaming content on YouTube
used to be predominantly consumed by guys.
But now I think you've
seen the gender disparity
has definitely gone
more towards the middle
and on some platforms
like Twitter, Twitch,
it's gone the other way.
It's one of those things
where it very much is
dependent on the platform
as to whether you're gonna
have more men or women on it.
But I definitely would say
that the Minecraft community overall
it probably used to be more dominated
by guys and that more guys played it
but now I think it's definitely
a lot closer to the middle.
- [Antfrost] I had disagree with the bats.
If you had asked me five years ago
or maybe two or three years ago,
I would be all the way over there
just based on my experience,
who I interacted with
and saw in the community.
I would definitely say
it was dominated guys
but guys just looked
at my YouTube analytics
and it's like 70% female and 30% male.
So I think more recently
it's definitely evened out a lot more.
I wouldn't say this really
dominated one way or the other.
- [Narrator] I actually enjoy Minecraft.
Three,
two,
one,
go.
(calm music)
- [Sipover] There's
different phases for me,
in enjoying the game,
but right now it's just
more of a content thing.
I like making the content for the game.
That's fun to me,
but you know I don't hop on survival mode
in my free time and start playing
'cause it's just gotten kind of old to me.
That's why I like making
content for it though
'cause it spices it up.
- [Nihachu] I've been playing
Minecraft for a while too,
but I never played it much.
I also definitely enjoyed
playing other things more
in my free time,
but I enjoyed a lot for the things
that I am doing currently.
- [Hannahxxrose] I enjoy
playing it on my streams
and on videos.
But just for the fact I've been
playing it for eight years,
I haven't played Minecraft
offline in a survival server
in probably six years on my
own time, on my own server.
I feel like I've done everything
that can possibly be done
and I'd rather play something
else in my free time
so I could save that content
for my stream or for a video
so it's more fun when it's
actually happening in real time.
- [BadBoyHalo] I think
that's a good point.
I do enjoy Minecraft,
doesn't mean there's not things about it
that I've gotten bored with 'cause I have,
but I've always found
there's something else
I can go and do in the meantime instead
or try something different.
But you said something interesting
and I think I'll move
a teeny bit more here.
There have been things that I'm like,
"Oh, I really wanna go and
try this thing in Minecraft."
Then I'm like,
"Oh no, wait, I shouldn't because
if I do this on a stream or
something or in my content,
my audience will enjoy it more
if I'm seeing it for the first time too."
So that has hindered
the enjoyment somewhat
by trying not really being able to try.
It's none of the really
cool stuff like off stream
in my free time before I
show my audience at first.
- I've been playing Minecraft
for about maybe eight or
nine years at this point.
I've always consistently been
just doing something else.
I haven't been doing like
the same exact, I don't know,
for example, play Minecraft survival
for nine years straight or whatever.
I've just changed up the type of things
I would do in the game
for it to be refreshing
and for me to enjoy it
whether it would be like PVP
speed run servers or whatever,
I'd enjoy Minecraft,
but I'll do different things in Minecraft.
(upbeat music)